[Music]
against you
they told me nope
who can't help you I could move my arms
and they said like be happy with this
but I
I never believed that
I couldn't walk anymore
[Music]
to walk the brain must send a command to
the region of the spinal cord
responsible for the control of movements
when there is a spinal cord injury this
communication is interrupted
our idea was to re-establish this
communication with a digital Bridge like
an electronic communication between the
brain and the region of the Spiral of
God that is still intact that can
control the neck
[Music]
foreign
surgery at the level of the brain we do
two little craniotomy put electrodes in
order to record the brain signal and
another surgery at the level of the
spinal cord where we put electrodes on
the top of the spinal cords at the place
that is responsible for leg movement
within five to ten minutes
I could control my
hips like they were like
brain implants picked up what I was
doing with my hips so that was like
the best outcome I think for everyone
[Music]
so the key next step for the company
onward medical we are working with is to
miniaturize these devices and make them
completely wearable and easy to use in
daily life
[Music]
really built functional things from it
to just an example I'm training 10 years
to stand up with a fence
having a beer
and that's something I think people
don't realize